Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and I have some
awesome news.
Studio Mir, the animation studio behind all
of the best Korra just signed a deal with
Dreamworks to produce 4 new animated 2-D tv
shows.
That’s four different shows, not just four
seasons of one show.
So I’ll do a breakdown of the deal, what
it means for future Avatar Series and the
future of Mike and Bryan.
I know a lot of you guys want more Avatar,
and based on a couple of big things, including
this Studio Mir stuff here’s probably what’s
going to happen.
Bare minimum, they’ll release the new Korra
games they already announced.
The game is from Platinum, it’s just called
The Legend of Korra.
You can download it on the Playstation Network
October 21st and on the Xbox Marketplace the
next day on the 22nd.
It’s a super cool fighting game which I’m
totally going to be buying, It’s only $15
Dollars so I’d recommend you guys get it.
The cast of the show did the voices for the
game too like Janet Varney, PJ Byrne, David
Faustino.
There’s supposed to be a ton of Bolin jokes.
There’s a Fire Ferrets Pro Bending mode
you can play in but you have to play through
the story mode once to unlock it.
Actually, you know what.
I’ll probably do a giveaway and hand out
some game codes or something like that.
It’s a couple weeks aways.
So why don’t we say just make sure you’re
subscribed and leave comments on at least
the Korra videos I post and I’ll just comb
through those to pick random winners.
I should have like 6 or 7 more Korra videos
out by then.
Speaking of more Avatar Universe content.
Studio Mir totally just won the lottery.
Here’s the details of that Dreamworks deal.
They signed a 4 year contract to co-produce
and distribute 4 separate animated shows.
Each show will be 78 episodes just like Korra
is.
Remember, that’s everything from book 1
to book 4.
They’re not Avatar based shows, they’ll
be new IP that Dreamworks and Studio Mir are
developing together.
The deal itself from a financial standpoint
is huge.
Before this, usually what you’d see is a
Major Studio like Dreamworks or Nickelodeon
would have a series they needed animated by
an overseas studio.
What happens most of the time is that the
overseas animation studios get hired as subcontractors.
So they get paid a very small fee and have
no creative control over the content.
Studio Mir is going to be co-producing these
4 new shows, so they’ll actually get a say
in what the finished product looks like.
If you listened to the interview Bryke just
did, he talks about the economics and political
aspects of traditional animation production.
So Studio Mir really did win the lottery,
Dreamworks or Dreamworks animation I should
say is a huge company badly in need of a successful
series.
Most of their films haven’t made big Pixar,
Disney Money.
Frozen for example, just became the highest
grossing animated film of all time last year.
So high fives to Studio Mir for being so amazing
at their jobs and high fives to Dreamworks
for recognizing talent when they see it.
The big question is, are Mike and Bryan attached
to run any of these new shows?
Answer is we don’t know yet.
They are looking for a new project.
But they have a history of developing their
own material.
And in the quote about the Dreamworks deal
there was no mention of what the subject of
the shows would be.
They have been friends with the Studio Mir
people since it was formed.
Avatar the original series was basically how
their relationship started.
The animation director on the original avatar
series started Studio Mir when Mike and Bryan
hired him to animate Legend of Korra.
In order to meet demand on Korra Studio Mir
grew to the place where it is today.
So without Avatar and Bryke, there would be
no Studio Mir.
That doesn’t guarantee Mike and Bryan will
be involved in any of the Dreamworks shows,
but I hope they at least come on board as
producers for Dreamworks.
What does all of this mean for the future
of the Avatar Series?
Right now Nickelodeon owns the rights to all
things Avatar.
Like I mentioned in my Book 4 predictions
video.
They will totally keep producing the comic
with Darkhorse and keep making video games
as long as they’re profitable.
There’s way more money in gaming than in
film and television.
A movie earning a billion dollars is crazy,
but games can make up to tens of billions
of dollars.
So there will be more Avatar Universe content.
But probably not television shows.
Keep in mind that in another 4 or 5 years,
they can totally do a Ninja Turtles and reboot
the series.
But without Mike and Bryan I don’t know
that it would be as good.
Here’s a big question for you guys.
Would you watch another Avatar series in 3
or 4 years if Mike and Bryan had nothing to
do with it?
I definitely wouldn’t be as excited about
it.
But regardless of whether or not they get
involved with the Dreamworks stuff, they will
continue to do new shows.
They actually just did another podcast with
Janet Varney.
For those that don’t know Janet has her
own Podcast called JV Club.
Usually her guests are actresses and female
personalities from the entertainment business.
She does a lot of comedy work in real life
like Sketchfest, so she has a lot of comedians
on too.
The Bryke Pod isn’t really about Korra,
they mostly talk about Mike and Bryan’s
lives growing up and some of their big influences.
It’s really cool.
I’ll add a link in the description.
They recorded the podcast during a break from
working on Book 4 audio work.
At this point in the production cycle I think
they already wrapped official voice recording,
so now they’re probably just working on
revising little things.
They will be at New York Comic Con next month,
so if you live in the area make sure to go
see the Korra panel.
They’ll probably be teasing book 4 stuff.
They’re really good about bringing concept
art for characters.
But I’m not expecting them to reveal anything
spoilery.
So the real story is, Lots more Studio Mir
coming in the near future.
Maybe some new Bryke stuff coming in the near
future.
They’ve said for the last couple of years
that they want to take another break after
Book 4 wraps production.
So it’s totally possible they’ll just
unplug and take a long vacation.
I don’t think they’ll be announcing any
new projects anytime soon though.
That would steal a little thunder from Korra
Book 4.
If they do have a new show, they’ll probably
wait to announce it until the last few episodes
of Korra are over.
I’ll continue to follow them whatever their
next project is.
They’re amazing at building worlds.
So hopefully their next series is an action
adventure anime.
Here’s my last question for you guys, do
you want to see them continue to work with
Studio Mir and what would you want those new
Dreamworks shows to be?
I know we’re all think some crazy new adventure
anime series.
Dreamworks wouldn’t have hired a studio
known for anime if they didn’t want that
kind of look for their shows.
Just something to think about.
Feel free to suggest other Anime Series for
me to check out.
I will be doing Star Wars Rebels videos starting
in October.
That’s going to be a Monday night show.
So Mondays will be like my Gotham Batman Star
Wars days this fall.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And right now, since I’m still in the middle
of moving to a new apartment there won’t
be a Korra Q&A, but I will have a new Doctor
Who bonus video tomorrow morning.
If you’re not watching the show yet, episode
1 just aired.
So you still have time to jump on.
Right now click here for my Korra Book 4 predictions
and click here to catch up with Doctor Who
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!